there's some discomfort it's this is les
laurenson
a cambridge trained solicitor sharing
his account of living with covert 19.
you have to trust your immune system and
if the
alternative is that we live in fear that
we create a bogeyman
out of something that hopefully i'm
showing
isn't anything to be afraid of taylor
blake just days after recording that
video
he died the 58 year old believed he was
fit enough
to not need the vaccine highly educated
in the letter of the law
yet tragically misguided in the
virulence of the virus
today his family said their final
goodbyes
doesn't seem real i mean watching you
know your
11 year old son writing the very last
card he knows he's ever going to write
to his dad
to put in the coffin with him you know i
had him crying in the car yesterday he
just said i missed daddy so much and i
don't know how to put it right for him
i don't i can't fix it i can't fix it
a letter no child wishes to write their
parent and no
parent wishes their child to write on
the second of july amanda who also had
covert 19
deteriorated and needed to go to
hospital as her 19 year old son
taylor went to tell les he found him
unresponsive
i've walked in i'm just like saying his
name no response
and kind of wasn't sure nfl he was a
pale guy anyway
if i quickly like he looks a bit more
pale than usual turned the light on
and he's just like this horrible like
she looked like concrete
his family want his death to warn others
it's awful it's heartbreaking and i've
got my two youngest brothers now
they've lost their dad and that's
there's nothing that my my mom said
there's nothing we can do to change that
and it breaks my heart every day
and i just don't want anyone else to
have to enjoy what we're enduring
having been through it and seeing how
it's ripped our family apart
please please rethink a lot of the stuff
that's out there isn't
fact it's scaremongering some of it and
i
really wish you'd reconsider a plea
that they hope will change minds and
maybe
save lives ashanaharanag sky news in
bournemouth